i said if i go to prison i'ma blow all
the dudes the first day
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to
oh my god hi
with me george lopez let's do
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george lopez
support for the oh my god hi podcast is
brought to you by
manscape who is the best in men's
trimming below the base champion
groomers of the world manscape
offered precision engineering for you
and the family jewels
manscape just launched their fourth
generation trim of the new lawnmower 4.0
you heard that right the 4.0 and join
over 2 million worldwide
who trust manscape with the exclusive
offer for you 20
off and free worldwide shipping with the
code
omg hi at manscape.com
you seen one of these things gil never
put that microphone right there
when did uh i don't
when did marijuan when when did drug
testing and workplace
start when people started to not show up
or what
probably
personal question vietnam no in vietnam
i
i didn't touch this stuff but in vietnam
you could buy a pack of cool cigarettes
it came in a cigarette pack they would
just fill them up they'd
empty out the tobacco fill it with weed
reseal the package and sell them they
were they were easy
vietnam it was easy they've never had
this in vietnam they would have said
listen what are we fighting for
you guys get one you guys get some yeah
down there hey stop that kid for [ __ ]
crying we're gonna give give me one of
these
they would have been in in mimi's mode
right it would have been
peace in the valley yep helicopters just
flying into each other
this thing right here the first cassette
tape i ever saw my friend andy
pulls up he's playing cat scratch fever
i'm like what's that
and the eight-track was bigger this was
his brother raymond's car
smaller thing in there and he takes
he hits it and it ejects i go what's
that first time ever because it's a
it's called a cassette tape like you put
it in there
it's got two sides and you know how
eight track you have to wait till the
song's over
or if you know halfway during the a song
on number four if you click it to number
one the
your favorite song will be started like
you get all the dynamics
and he put it in there and never seen a
cassette and
when these dudes were using this last
week on your podcast
i i couldn't i couldn't [ __ ] believe
what i was seeing
that's yeah it those things are
devastating man
especially when you use flour right like
we use it we use them we open it up
can we open it when what we're still
talking about yeah yeah i mean when
like when we use it we use it with the
concentration you gotta have the wife
call you to come and pick you up
[Laughter]
wow i gotta wanna i wanna do it it's
justice but this is uh
all right where's your man egg i see it
help him out better better will help him
out
listen so yeah b tell him what's in here
bro because you know i was the kind of
kid since i was the only child and i
hardly got presents that i would break
the [ __ ] thing trying to open it
right
one [ __ ] wing of the plane cracked so
what pedro is taking out now is the base
of the gravity bong right and and
and the two glass pieces are called
bulbs
right and those are big ones they make
slightly smaller ones
but those these ones are the the
primaries right here right
and water goes on the bottom one
because you're gonna what you're gonna
do to get the smoke to come out of it
is flip it okay and and the pressure
from the water coming
down makes the smoke um you know the
pressurizing come through the come
through the bulb
and then and then when you flip it again
it pushes the smoke out
of the tube you know what i mean and
then it's go time
this thing is the craziest you
understand that like water pressure and
yeah it's the pressure amongst itself
the water pushes it out yeah it's a
high-tech gravity bomb
and you could use this one with uh for
with flour
right it's got a bowl for flowers right
there which is that's the one
and like when you when you want to rock
the flower you want to put a little bit
in there you don't want to put a lot of
flour because every time you flip it
it's just going to get more stale
you sort of want to put a little bit of
flour and then
flip it as many times to snap that look
at gill's face he's like i wish i had my
[ __ ] hand coated but if you put a lot
of flour in there
if you put a lot of flour in there and
you flip that it's going to create a
lot of it's going to be milky and
whoever takes that
sleep sleep for the rest of the day hey
could i put this on in my bedroom at
night and just
yeah flip it until i pass out [ __ ] yeah
yeah right yeah
it's gonna go into the air absolutely
papa that can be like lights out
a [ __ ] dog people knock it up your
dogs are in the street
people come to the studio and they want
to you know try this right
and most often than not they they need
to sit down for a while
yeah maybe take a little nappy nap
before they
leave i mean if you have to take a nappy
nap you're [ __ ] up even some of our
guys
have been put out by this like easy he's
he's put himself
out with one of these right here with
but with concerts
is it like ikea where it doesn't have
all the parts yeah and uh so
there's something they're there for oh
no right
no no everything's good but for
concentrates we use a thing called the
connect the g
pen connect right and yeah that little
square battery
and a little it's a little tube for the
concentrate we use it
with with this right that's what really
puts people out
that [ __ ] right there like the flower
does too but that right there
is like that's when it puts guys on our
our couch of comfort yeah right where
you feel like you can fall asleep on
that
couch and you're safe nobody's gonna
draw on your face
it's like a sanctuary you know i'm
saying anyone who falls asleep on this
couch
cannot you know we don't [ __ ] with them
oh don't the only thing that gets
that happens to them is maybe an
inconvenient photograph
you know i'm saying yeah yeah but we
don't allow the writing on the face
because we're grown-ass men
did you ever hear that story like
somebody got their house broken into and
then there was a camera there
and the guys that were robbing robbing
them took pictures of their werewolves
and put like
their toothbrushes in their food
and they left the camera back there they
didn't take the camera they would they
developed the film you see oils with an
oral b sticking out of it oh man well
they're nuts
they're going out they're doing that
they're like crazy just put the camera
back that'll be for
you yeah you can do that now [ __ ]
the uh is it considered a hookah
you couldn't use it for a hookah too you
you know you could you could you could
use it for three different things right
you could use it for the flower right
there
you can use it for um the concentrate
and it comes
with the hookah adapter so if you wanted
to rock the hookah
you could this is almost some [ __ ] that
bugs bunny would have you know yeah
like marvin the martian marvin yeah into
his house and you got one of these on
there
[ __ ] yeah and even it has an adjustable
you see everyone
yeah yep look at that if you want to
bring it down to your level
you know what else it comes with is a
wall mount so if you want to [ __ ]
wound it up
mount it on your wall in your garage
papa while you're doing work and you
need to work on yourself too
you know it comes with a wall mount
[ __ ] you're in the house right here
next to the paper towels what the [ __ ]
you're looking for looking for that
[ __ ] hookah
it's all behind you hey put that [ __ ] on
the wall keep [ __ ] losing it
man they've thought of everything
they have thought of everything when i
was i did his podcast last week gil and
uh
i i uh i don't really smoke a lot of
marijuana
but when you cough i guess you get high
faster that's what they say
yeah do you agree or disagree i think
you get high faster either way
cough or no cough it's just you know i
think psychologically
you're coughing and you know when you
call for sneeze
you cut the oxygen off to the head right
yeah you might get a little higher from
that but
let me ask you a question how many years
were you on the force sheriff's 38
38 years in your 38 years
if you walked into a house and it
smelled like weed
are you thinking guilty oh i know
there's a weed i
think you know i'm not hooking anybody
because you would say you know you're
trying to because back then
when i first went out weed was a felony
when i first hit the streets
that's crazy and these dudes had to do
detective where there was no dna
at 70 you could [ __ ] [ __ ] on somebody
and they go hey
i'm not going to look at the dead body
until you take that [ __ ] off him
and now they find a hair yeah in the
carpet
technology man it made it made their
that part of their job a little bit
easier right yeah i
i couldn't say this publicly
but if i had somebody could you just
scare the repercussions
if yeah it doesn't look good bring it
bring your hands in here if
if i'm supporting alex uh for sheriff
let me talk and stuff like that but it's
legal though but
back then when i went out right i didn't
pot peep
weed to me was nothing you know i really
didn't you do it ate
i drink i drank and did [ __ ] before i
was 21.
hey just toss it in the grill get it get
out of here it's one of those good
you know i really think good to know
good to know guys
that you know you you don't have you
didn't have to try to jump your back
wall
yeah car pull up yeah if you saw him
coming you know you could talk
yeah and that that goes a very long way
because there's
you know like when you're in the street
in the hood
you know you see certain cops pull
around the corner that you know
right because you've dealt with them
before or they have a reputation
you're either running or you're gonna
you're gonna you you know that you can
have a conversation that's why i became
a cop the cop that used to have a
conversation with the cops who wanted to
help out god
and i know now he was a great car you
know he still used pad astonishing
but i thought it was all just part of a
game that guy was good
the other guy robles who was a good
street cop
yeah but you'd say hey who is it it's
robles bam like rats everybody
right here wow yeah everybody run
because you know like
you know i came up gangbanging right and
uh all of us knew the certain names of
the certain cops that would be the ones
patrolling our hoods
and we knew the ones that we had to run
from because
they were going to come break our balls
and we knew the ones that we could talk
to
because they weren't looking just for
like some petty [ __ ] to lock you up for
they were coming to have like a rapport
with you and and
so they they were kind of cool they
would check you
now and then to let them know hey listen
right
this is what it is we'll [ __ ] you up
right now we'll we'll put you in this
car and take you down
but if you're cool let's just have a
conversation
right and you know sometimes
we knew those guys we knew who we could
talk to and who
we definitely didn't want to talk to was
that part of a strategy as a police
officer or is that the guy's personality
personality like he was that way in high
school football
treat something you learned treat people
the way you'd like to be treated
that's all it was it was really simple
if you had to go to jail you wanted to
go in my car you didn't want to go to
anybody else's car
i've had murder suspects talk to my wife
on the phone yeah
yeah hey damn screw hey you know you
don't man he's there chaos
yep you know and that's good i buy
burritos for the guys
you're going to jail hey why'd you buy
them you ain't going to get this [ __ ] in
there hey man
i'll tell you there was a guy there
there was an officer clarkson i don't
remember his first name
officer clarkson anytime this dude came
around
it was it was like a gamble you either
ran
or you you sat there and talked to him
he wasn't gonna ask you anything that
was gonna compromise you
but he was checking the pulse of every
neighborhood
right he wasn't because he knew nobody
was gonna give him any
information but he could at least check
the pulse right and
every now and then when he'd come guys
would what run
and he knew all of us so you know
because we all had a profile
so he knew who ran and who didn't so the
next time
he'd roll up he'd let you know hey would
you run from me last time for
right come the [ __ ] over here
right and stuff like that and but he
would he would treat you
fairly but he would make sure and shake
you to let you know
you know don't [ __ ] around and uh he was
ice cold we all respected him
we didn't like him but we respected him
enough to be like okay don't run from
this [ __ ] because
he may catch us slipping somewhere else
and it's it's gonna be awful next time
so let's just
let's just be cool right here and he
sometimes he was cool sometimes
and i think i think it's a cat you know
first of all there's a cat and a mouse
game
played in crime sure yeah no doubt it's
a game
okay oh and there's when did good cop
bad cops start when do you think that
that felt i thought that's from the
way back yeah yeah i i know it was there
before i got there
you need a you need a guy who's acting
like he's sympathizing with
you while his partner is grilling the
[ __ ] out of you amazing
because it it might break you down
not every it doesn't work for everybody
but it might break
down it works it works with new guys
fish
veterans you know guys that have been
through his system it's almost like
dudes that are homosexual they go hey
are you the pitcher or the catcher
and
one cop can't do it on it's on his own
no dude doesn't want to talk
it's it's like parents do to their kids
[ __ ] completely
[ __ ] i told you no oh [ __ ] there he goes
say no and that never happens and good
cop in the marriage
well i had i had to look i got divorced
i'm the i had to be the best
i think for it to be balanced you have
to like you know
divide it yeah switch it out sometimes
do you see that played you guys played
that right
sure and
are you trying to get a confession
you're trying to get names from other
people
because what were you you're just trying
to solve the crime right
we're just trying to get information out
of them whether it's a confession
get them to roll over on somebody give
us something that we don't know about
that that's what you're trying but that
good cop bad cop
only works when you're dealing with new
gangsters you know
youngsters that haven't been through
been through system once they've been
through a system they'll look at you and
they'll laugh
or just people that aren't necessarily
in the criminal lifestyle but they
[ __ ] up somewhere you know out of
a bad decision yeah yeah those those
folks would break real quick like that
because they're not career criminals
do you remember right that's right right
because they're yeah they don't
they don't want to be they're not career
criminals and they don't want to go to
jail
this is all new to them they're scared
they're scared shitless
what was the worst time for
gang banging and crime in los angeles or
or you know around the country because
because i remember when they said
don't flash your lights if somebody's
driving around at night on the light
you're
the lights of a car in the 90s right
yeah yeah
don't hit your high beams because that
car will come around
and they were shooting people yeah
because that was watching their high
initiations for some gangs with that
right
in the 70s in east l.a that was the gang
capital
of the nation right i had geraldo rivera
riding around with me on nightline
you know during in the 70s doing stuff
on gangs
and so that was it then as time
progressed
and they had gangs in the south inn in
south central yeah
and the crips and the blood were just
starting back then
but they weren't organized they were bad
these the guys from sally
were bad they they were tough as nails
and you go down to
the south side and they'd give up their
mother that's where that's where you're
back just call them i think it's
right so south where did you start yeah
in south central south central
but that but it's true yeah i mean it's
it's really true like in in terms of
of the lack of organization you know
just wasn't there there was no protocols
you know some guys stood
hard in the paint you know and gave up
nothing
but other guys definitely did then as
they started progressing
everybody became more educated never
they became more sophisticated in
everything they were doing
and it became harder and harder through
the 80s to solve murders because they
became transient and they were doing
stuff
yeah they were doing sophisticated [ __ ]
then but let's say like in beretta
remember beretta
that had the buffalo keep your eye on
this don't remember he had rooster yeah
he had the rooster was the rat he was
the rata he'd go over there and lean on
his car and he's like hey man we're not
supposed to even be talking you know
yeah yeah and rooster was the guy that
was that was flipping over
turning over on every week there's
always somebody in there like that yeah
and everybody
there's somebody like that you see
i guess people oh man what's more what
what gives you more
street cred to not roll over on somebody
and then do your time and then get out
you got to be again i mean
in the street yeah i mean you know it's
valuable
because they know they could trust you
if they're doing the same [ __ ] you're
doing you know
you know you could trust somebody
because they didn't roll over
marijuana being a felony okay
how do we get marijuana being a felony
to being legal
smarter people but smarter people than
me
you know i think you know that's
attributed to you know people like
educating themselves about
cannabis and and you know throughout
um color weed weed marijuana whatever
that's like if you call a girl like you
go ah she's all right but if you say
she's gorgeous yeah cannabis is gorgeous
and weed is ah she's all right
yeah so i think we let's call it
cannabis it's all good it's beautiful
but you know
like people got educated about it and
they figured out okay like a lot of
people are going to jail for
this particular um plant
which is nowhere near the the other
drugs that that are available to people
out there
and you know i think they they also
educated themselves
on the possibilities and the economics
of it
and what what it can actually do for
people in terms of the
medicinal parts so people that didn't
necessarily smoke
they were like looking at that as as an
alternative people that don't want to
pop
pills and do all this other [ __ ] you
know they they found the properties that
they could use in cannabis
to you know use as their therapy
or their medication right their medicine
and more and more people just did the
diligence
and said okay how do we pass this so
that people stop
going to jail for this plant and that
we can actually start using it as
medicine without
being prosecuted for it and that we can
create industry from it because we know
that
you know it creates um revenue
like no other business yet you know we
get taxed
like crazy out here in cali but you know
it's it's
a business like no other and i think
people
started recognizing that you know in the
early 2000s
like in the 90s we all talked about it
you know a lot of us that that were in
hip-hop we talked about it freely we
were putting it out there but
i think in 2000 when when as technology
starts to
develop and um information is more
accessible
people got in the know like oh well this
[ __ ] ain't so bad we need to rally
around this
and people did and here we are snoop
dogg
snoop dogg made this [ __ ] popular a
felony these about those right here
i mean you know and it's not it's not
feral anymore like
like weed would just be you you didn't
know where it came from maybe it was
thai stick or
acapulco or some [ __ ] some name they had
for back in the day 70s around high
school
so you didn't know if it was gonna make
you paranoid if it was gonna put you
asleep
there's no information there's no
information on it one time on a sunday
i got invited to go to barbecue and see
me valet and the 118 wasn't totally up
yet so
me and another guy were were smoking and
driving and it's so
long to go to see uh to see me that i
got paranoid
and i started crying and
that dude had to take me home all from
off from half a joint
i was driving and thinking then i
started getting sad
he went to laughs
[Laughter]
i wouldn't i wouldn't say if i i said if
i go to prison i'm gonna blow
all the dudes in the first day what's up
guys who wants seconds tomorrow
that [ __ ] is crazy
[Laughter]
suck everybody's guards stop that
[ __ ] sucker
from the landing where
i was i was always afraid i hung around
with guys that were tougher but
i was always afraid of them i told you
that time they pulled a gun on me
if i went home and pulled covers over my
head you know sometimes being afraid
will keep you out of trouble
some of us that weren't so afraid man we
got in so much [ __ ] trouble
and uh you know but hey it was a
learning experience did you drop out of
high school
yeah i did what do you what what to what
did your parents say what what
what do you say to a kid now let's say a
kid
is like let's say he has to be underage
a lot of them understand smoke weed
as a parent if you're trying to get get
through to your kid as a parent
because what would you say is good
advice for
a parent to tell their kid about all
this you know i think they have
have to have a a respectful conversation
i mean i know you're the parent
right right and uh as now i'm 50 i'm a
parent right
um you have to have that respect and and
know that kids these days are very smart
you know they they have access to to
to information we did not have right so
talking to them
is much easier than it was for our
parents to talk to us because they had
old
outdated shitty information what about
the one where you think that was
effective where they had the frying pan
and they put the egg in there that
helped did that help you
that just made us hungry
he's like damn don't we got any eggs in
the refrigerator
that was the that was the anti-drug
campaign
yeah here's your brain yeah here's your
brain on drugs
i think kids these days are willing to
have that conversation
if if you have a decent enough
relationship with your kids if you don't
someone else is going to get you're not
giving yeah you know as a parent you
have to realize that you're not always
right
right you have to be flexible absolutely
and you may have to accept what he's
putting out
if you don't have if you haven't done
your homework then you have to accept
what he says
and maybe do a little more research but
just to come out and say no that's evil
well then you're bucking heads and he's
gonna do what he wants at what point do
you at what point would you lose your
your child or your dad you see the
movies where dad's you know it's
it's when you're restricting them and
stopping them from doing some [ __ ]
without
any information or explanation as to why
and in the the conversation that happens
back and forth there that
you know if if you're not given any
information or
anything that's relatable that they can
say you know what i
understand if you're just saying no
and and listen i'm your parent i don't
need to [ __ ] tell you why i know
what's good for you
you've lost them right there that or you
know
just not hate them you know you're right
you have
but maybe it's time to emancipate you
know really
i just don't want this going on in my
house really yeah i i don't
i i if i got to the point where it's
still my still my world still my house
and i lay down the law here i understand
you want to do what you want to do
but i can't have that in my house and
wow i would just
i love you i respect you but
the respect i'm asking people in return
is not in my house
and i'd stand firm wow dude emancipation
if that's what that's the term you know
some kids
they want that you know because they
might not be in a situation where they
feel their parents are
ever going to understand who they are
right
and what they need and you know in terms
of support
and you know um do you realize that if
you were britney spears dad she could
still be touring right now
oh with all her money no beef with her
dad her dad's all her money
yeah yeah but like that right when
you're talking to
yeah because once it becomes just no all
the time yeah
then you're gonna yeah you've lost them
yeah you've lost and i think they love
you
always because you're the parent but
when they don't respect you know without
a reason
and that you know that's happened to a
lot of us you know
don't do this why don't worry about why
don't do it
well [ __ ] what's what do they say right
what's the been the oldest saying
curiosity kills the cats right
some of the cats live my daughter asked
me
yeah a lot of cats came back off getting
it up
and with tattoos [ __ ] one ear my
daughter asked me dad when this log
it looks like it would pass are you
gonna
are are you gonna try weed
and i said i'm gonna start growing this
[ __ ] in my backyard i said we'll have it
here for everybody if you want
and she says are you serious i said no
oh my god you know what's awesome is
you know i watch a lot of different
stuff on youtube
manscaped i saw this guy so i'm
supportive of
the oh my god hi podcast is brought to
you by manuscript
engineer tools to protect your family
jewels join over 2 million
men worldwide who trust manscaped
with this exclusive offer for you 20 off
and
free worldwide shipping listen imagine
shaving with a sleek well-designed
optimized trimmer that makes shaving
time
your favorite time in the bathroom i've
tried the new 4.0
and i'm blown away by the performance
the craftsmanship and the details of 4.0
are on the next level
and i've had an accident where i had a
nick listen if you have a nick here
you think those things don't stop
bleeding i was with a young lady
and she said oh my god you're dying i
had nicked
one of my testicles with something that
wasn't manscaped that's not gonna happen
again
manscaped is engineered for the ultimate
growing
and body trimmer by focusing on the
intelligent function
engineering at ultimate groin and body
trimmer by focusing
on the functionality featured cutting
edge ceramic blade
and reduced grooming accidents
to their advanced skin safe technology
and now you can
feel comfortable shaving the boys
the uh upgrade trimmer includes a
multi-function on and off switch that
can engage
a travel lock because hey i'm gonna tell
you you know how important that is it
can engage a travel lock
if you've ever had a tooth electronic
toothbrush go off in your suitcase
they'll pull you in
and put their fist in your cool before
they find out that you left your
toothpaste on now they have an engaged
lock that you can travel with so that
doesn't happen so it also gives you the
ability to turn
uh 4000 k
it's an ltd spotlight that they have on
and off
when you need a more precise shave uh
the upgrade trimmer gives you a
multi-function on and off switch
um the lawnmower 4.0 even allows you to
customize your trim through additional
guard links
with sizes between one through four now
you see the way my hair is right now
that's a four
but when i look clean and look tight i'm
one and the 4.0 even allows you to
customize
everything did i mention that it's
wireless charging
your balls never had it so good and pops
number one the new wireless charging
system uses electron
the new wireless system charges the new
wireless charging system use
electromagnetic induction
which can help battery life
lasts longer if only we had it that good
hey treat your webers like i treat my
werewolves and go manscaped
and get 20 off free shipping with the
code
omghi at manscape.com if you're even not
if you're like listening you're like
i don't know if you don't know it's
better to know than not to know
and your webers will thank you and your
lady will thank you
i don't care who does it you know i'm
not a prude like and i don't give a [ __ ]
my kids do i i don't i really don't care
and and to tell you the truth
i don't do it because i don't have the
wells because and your wife too i
thought you're watching a documentary
if i could get you a [ __ ] closet
she don't mess around huh she's a lady
that she's a she's a lady but
and she's got it you know for no she
doesn't smoke but gotta take a little
bit of uh
cbd not sure the ecstasy what the [ __ ]
that
the jelly [ __ ] the candy the chocolate
the gummies
the gummy bears you know yeah for pain
absolutely
and and my i won't mention today but my
doctor
said hey i give it to my mother yeah
that's my
my medical medicine going you know
i use this for my mother yeah and so
there's got to be something to it
after 38 years of being a cop and 38
years of being a virgin to this [ __ ]
right i'm you know i'm like a little kid
i want to try it that first time
but there's a stigma but i think that if
you ever
listen if you were going to fly you'd
want to fly with like chuck yeager
or yeah if you're going to play baseball
and you go well you know i need to get
you a hitting coach mickey meno come
over here so if you were
if you were going to try marijuana the
equivalent of
mickey mantle chuck yeager uh
uh if you wanted uh microsoft bill gates
to help you with your homework about the
right here is the
leo davinci i can see he's bringing out
this
to me this future [ __ ] i mean this is
something from star wars
here's solo right here that that's the
thing you know sin
when it became legal here and in other
places you had the people that were
already you know in the culture right
that
build up a tolerance they can smoke
anything and
it's they're going to always be level
right um
but there's others that are curious
about it i'm like oh well
it's legal i'll try it for the first
time and
if they go into a spot where the the bud
tenders aren't giving them the education
like
asking them so are you a first-time
smoker you know or
right or veteran spoke or whatever
question you would ask to know
what to like suggest to them because
some people come in
knowing exactly what they want right but
other people that
you know are just starting or they're
just trying it one time for the first
time or whatever
they'll come in with questions and the
butt tends to give you a little bit of a
headache
i'm right on it
and the bud tenders got to be able to
answer those questions so if they're
like a first-time
smoker and they're asking hey what this
is my first time what should
i try i don't want to feel this way
right and if the bud tender knows what's
what's happening
they'll give them something that's good
but light
so don't have a bad experience because
you don't ever want to give anybody a
bad experience you want them to
you know embrace it and if they should
try to and if they come back
they come back and if they lost them
they tried it for my [ __ ] luck i
tried some of that [ __ ] my swag and i
would come back
the mother-in-law came back with a
curtain
the uh you're
[Laughter]
hey so so i'm gonna say that i believe
that 100
of what you said i think that's
education is a thing
but as this starts to grow and as it
starts to spread then
the the culture has a responsibility to
make sure that
when somebody goes in there for the
first time and says that you know what
you want to try that that person behind
the counter
knows what knows what they're talking
about absolutely i think the biggest
i think the biggest divide is that
if you've never been with it and it's
legal now i think you're going to be
against it naturally but also
i don't think if somebody would talk to
that person they might come around and
say yeah they might lower the guard yeah
and and i want to reiterate i'm not
against it at all
and and the only reason i don't is all
these guys that i worked with for years
you know
oh now you're wondering yeah yeah and
and i just don't want those things yeah
and i know that half the guys i worry
about
i know they're doing this [ __ ] yeah i
mean that that's right they just don't
talk about it
cops cops are people too in spite of
what others might think
yeah and and they don't want to be
popping the pills either
right you know so if cannabis um works
to whatever
[ __ ] there's you know having to take
these pills for
they'll take the cannabis i mean there
was a a dispensary in roseman
um you know out there towards uh
lancaster whatever and uh
la sheriffs would go by their cannabis
there they don't want to be seen buying
cannabis in in la shops because united's
places they patrol and [ __ ] like that
so they would go but some of them would
go buy their cannabis up there and
you know it was medicine for them so
it's
it's when i was in uh laughlin they have
a big store there
and i was after some ointment yeah not
the oil
but the ointment i'll tell you how old
it was
liniment [ __ ] and i went in you know you
sat there and then they called you in
you go inside this door locked door a
lot of people inside
uh would you call them the dispensary
the
active the the people that are selling
the ships oh the bud tenders
the bud tenders bunch of blood tenders
in there yeah is that the description of
it like
i looked in the paper for a job and i
said bud tender yeah that's yeah that is
the counter guy instead of a cashier
they're called bud tenders
okay and so i go in this place and i
felt like
man people are watching me you know i'm
a yep
mom and i'm already retired but i mean
i know but let me tell you if you're
already paranoid like that you don't
need weed you're already
you're already [ __ ] tripped out with
never trying it so listen buddy
if i if you and i were together you go
jordan i watch it but hey you know what
you're already [ __ ] crazy right now
i gotta get into this she's mixing
he's already looking over his shoulder
and start crying driving
but but but i would say that
like that because you know never really
doing it myself
but i i like it but i don't i don't do
much of it because i i can't
handle a lot of it but
i know how good it is medically and i
think hey
all my grandmother used to have a bottle
of alcohol that was old oh yeah
leaves in it and that's what that's what
that's what it that's what it is right
yeah yeah
people would use it on their joints and
[ __ ] like that
um it's old school yeah i remember
seeing my grandmother with it too my
grandma put it on her knees and she go
jord
can you go to the am pm and and with ice
45 corn dogs
at a 45 piece i'm starting to get a
little bit hungry
i gotta be [ __ ] tearing up the
kitchen like what the [ __ ] is she doing
shut
the [ __ ] up she was high on her knees
when her elbow just alcohol in the back
of her neck
she works my my uh my graduation ring
for her
for her jones eh a very dear friend of
mine i don't even know what jones is
got cancer you have pancreatic cancer
and a lot of
pain and he would say excuse me and he
wanted he didn't want to smoke
a joint in front of me because he didn't
want to
i said ain't no disrespect you're my
friend smoke
smoke to your heart because that's the
only thing that would kill this pain
right and he only lasted about two and a
half
three months and that's the only thing
that kept him going
it's excruciating pain and
i would say that you know us when you
see somebody go through
that much pain
this is better for them than oh yeah
sure than
morphine and all that [ __ ] they use
because i mean you could take all those
prescription drugs that they give you to
suppress any of the [ __ ] that you're you
know
you're trying to get um you know therapy
for
whatever you know um but that stuff is
really high concentrated right the stuff
that
yes somebody would be given some of it
some of it's it's it's you know highly
dosed and stuff because
people want more more um milligrams than
others but
the one thing that that we do know is
that
when you take some of this prescription
medication
it may be suppressing the thing that
that you're dealing with now but it
creates other problems in your organs
and your liver
much later and people are smarter now
they know
like i don't want to be taking this [ __ ]
because i know that this is
you know this is going to be the death
of me well it's supposed to be helping
me from this
so you know more people are willing to
to
to try different types of things and
cannabis is one of those things where
if if it can treat you medically for
whatever you're taking this other
[ __ ] for people are willing to try
it because they know
there's no side effects other than the
munchies or you're high or paranoia
but realistically you're not damaging
yourself you're actually healing
yourself let's say if you knew somebody
in their early 70s who never tried
uh weed um
and explain to him the difference
between
who's overweight tv no no they were you
and
the difference between cbd and thc
well see you know the difference between
yes
thc has the cannabis that would get you
high
yeah that's yeah and the tcb has no
effects on your
getting yourself latino they've all got
all this [ __ ] wrong cbd not a tcp
take your business
everything was a [ __ ] you were like
you had to figure that [ __ ] out like
what did she say and the tender
is the one that explained it to me
because i wanted something for arthritis
from my joint
and he said well this one is more potent
and this one is not so much and so i
took the one that was more poignant
potent and it works yeah it does it does
work on my arthritic on my
right and i'd scream that to the world
it works yeah some
people take cbds with just cbd no thc
but the one that's more effective is the
one that has
a little bit of both what if you have
guilt to be a spokesperson like bob this
big boy like put a little plate into
something like that
and he'll have some cookies on some weed
like bob's big boy
outfit right there baby uh but
um is it consistent it stays
is it like a pill that it goes away and
then you have to redo it or
would it stay in your system longer or
does it completely fade
what do you mean uh if you took the
appointment and and it kind of
and i mean like everything you know it
it's it's
something you would have to take
regularly like unless
does it clear your system completely if
i
i never had to test after it but here's
we we talked about this this last week
when you called me when i was over in
canyon lake yeah uh
and this battle has a life most chicanos
in his age at home
they were talking because they leaned
back and aren't things broken so they
pushed themselves i'm
kicking it yeah the the gummy bears
you know and they were they were talking
about the medicinal stuff and i just
told them that with any pain you know
medic even pain medication whatever you
think you got pain
all of a sudden it doesn't say okay the
pain's gone
you just notice sometimes hey you know
two hours down the road you're saying
i don't feel that anymore you know it's
gone so it doesn't just like turn
turn the light off or on it just
dissipates
and then you forget when you don't have
the pain you're not worried about you're
not thinking about it anymore it's not
in your mind and they usually last the
whole day okay i'm going to tell you a
story
my wife used to go to pebble beach in
the summer and i would be there working
so one sunday i have a brownie four
times
so i eat a little bit of the brownie at
first i'm watching tv and all of a
sudden i'm just picking at it i forgot
that it's four times
so i'm just kind of picking at it and
i'm eating it and then
it's empty and i said oh [ __ ] i ate that
whole
four times brownie remember that that
movie boxing helena was just
yeah yeah yeah i was in the bed and it
was just
the head would move like this like none
of my body was with a [ __ ] ring and i
was just like
myself upstairs and i was tripping dude
i could only move my head and try to
answer the phone with my mouse
i was i was [ __ ] up incapacitating
incapacitated
incapacitated completely gone
so all right that's good yeah that's
just good too
you know it's it's one of those things
like these days you know
the every every single one is dosed
properly by any
any company and they'll tell you okay
the bagging total is x amount
milligrams um and each one
is x amount of milligrams per serving so
you know
how much you're taking right in the old
days it was like a year
i don't have this but don't eat the
whole thing
and then we ate the whole thing
completely remember that there's the
whole thing
on the road i don't feel [ __ ] and then
you eat the whole [ __ ] thing
and then in 20 minutes [ __ ] up
let me tell you i was in a white house
in hawaii and i tried a cookie in the
beginning it didn't work i had another
one so i'm waiting there in front of the
restaurant
for it to uh hit and then it hits and
then
all asian couple walked out and to me
they looked like cats that were wearing
fantasy
stop laughing they had to tell me to get
out of the restaurant
i just saw them as cats walking it
looked like a like a almost like a
valentine's day card
cats of the tuxedo the other cats in a
dress and they walked by me and i just
i couldn't stop laughing at the little
chinitos were cats
for dinner but but if somebody if
if somebody out there i think this would
probably be the toughest situation if
if you had your husband or your wife
that was in a lot of pain
and you hadn't gone here you hadn't gone
to this yet
and you want to what's their first
what's the best step for them to start
i mean that's a situation called call
that's right you know like i call george
and say hey george put me in touch with
with somebody who knows yeah because i
wouldn't hesitate to give it to my wife
somebody was in pain
yeah not at all and then you tell them
small doses in the beginning so that
they can build their tolerance up and
later they take more and it'll be more
effective
you know what i mean but you know if
you're just doing it recreationally
some people will have half the bag in a
day and just be toasted
but you know for someone who's just
starting yeah you call someone who knows
and hopefully the the bud tender that is
dealing with you
if you bought it at a dispensary um
most especially a licensed one you
should you should buy these at licensed
dispensaries don't buy them
at the shops how do you know if it
doesn't have a if it doesn't have a
license
well you know most of them they're
selling out of their back door
yeah they're selling their licenses yeah
well because there's a lot of gives you
a tire goes
don't look in the tire right now let me
get out of here well they're called
rogue shops right but they can't really
they're
they're not advertised like they might
have a small green cross to not
like you know have a big ass sign like
so and so they'll be getting shut down
they're
they'll be after well there's they must
be and they should be and
eventually they will be but if you go
buy anything from there
most likely it's untested and and
maybe the dosage ain't what it says on
the back because it
might be a bootleg bag so if if you're
beginning
best to find yourself a licensed
dispensary and go there and ask the bud
tender hey
i'm you know beginning i'm a beginner on
this what should i have and how many
milligrams
should i have should i start off with
and you know if they know
what you know what if the tender has
been trained properly they'll know what
to tell them
you know but i would say start off low
doses
what is a shelf life um for edibles
usually they have two hours
[Laughter]
i mean these are the layers
i believe that there's expiration date
on any you know any uh
consumer consumable product so as long
as you have it before then the thc
or the cbds that are in there are gonna
you know they're gonna stay in there
because they're they're infused it's not
like
flour where you know it might get dry
brittle and it might lose some of its
impact
um this is infused so it it never does
i mean i i would suppose you don't want
to you know keep it two years and then
bite into it but does it lose its
potency over time
no wow no it's infused it ain't it's not
going to lose the potency
it's pretty good i would like to see my
grandfather
can you put it could you put it in the
tortilla you probably
i think you could i believe you i
believe you can
you know anything you use like whether
it's oils or or butters or any type of
[ __ ] like that um anything so in the
beginning that came out like
steak sauce and peanut butter that stuff
they still have that but i mean you
could put it in anything you could put
anything
i mean i did a show called bong appetit
right and it's it was uh
it was um it was a show um
was a show about um it was a competitive
show about
chefs some of them that were familiar
with cannabis others that weren't
on who can make the best infused meal it
was on vice that we did it
know they were infusing every meals they
had to make us uh
um an appetizer the entree
and then dessert in every aspect of it
they found a way to infuse something
in there so you know yeah
it could be your salad dressing it could
be whatever you're sauteing the
vegetables with it could be
you know it could be in anything
do you think we'll come to a point where
let's say somebody has a cow farm or
veal that you'd be giving weed to the
cows and veal to make them like
grass-fed organic
because they're already you know like
that dude one time i think they're just
going to create
a tuna with
where they can grow the you know kobe
steak
and that would be meal to get to get
that animal on a diet
of cannabis cannabis
they said goats used to love to eat um
cannabis sounds like that's why while
our parties are good
you'd have to be smoking their turds
yeah
and your body you know after a certain
amount of period it's gone it dissipates
it
your body pushes it out you want to know
what's crazy is that on that bong
appetit show
they had this lady that um she was from
mexico but she was living up north
and she was going to try to do you know
that's a that's five million people in
california
yeah there was a lady that she was from
basically she lives up north
narrowed it down she was originally from
this part of mexico
and she like with her family she moved
up north some
some years back but what she was trying
to do was create
her her uh her mother's recipes
in this infusion [ __ ] and she did
she did uh alvon digas with goat
instead of ground beef she she did
ground goat
and infused the albundigaz and they were
the [ __ ] bombs it was the best it was
the best alvondiga albondigas i've had
ever and they were infused and it was
goat
it was goat meat i'm just asking for a
friend where's she
at i'll find out i'll find out
because i know they got a they got a a
small restaurant up there i'll find out
where she's at you know what you could
go try something if if we could do that
it would make going to baptisms less
[ __ ] a pain in the ass
you know what was crazy is that like
that there was a certain
you would eat first and then go baptize
the kid so
so the reason she used goat right ground
goat meat was because like
you know there was there was uh three to
four chefs right pedro there were three
to four
and uh they all had a race they had the
race to get their proteins right
so the old lady was the last one over
there she was just
walking while the other young folks are
running and they left her with the goat
so she was like
[ __ ] it i'm going to we're going to
ground this [ __ ] up and i'm going to
make alon de gaza and she
killed it wow that's like it's pretty
amazing
yeah if you could make up wonders that
had that were infused
they were the [ __ ] cream of wheat hmm
huh mashed potatoes are ross with that
rice pudding the thing uh flan
flan and candles they have i'll probably
put two is my nipple right there taking
pictures
uh man yeah i think that i think that
there's a bigger
i think ultimately i think what they saw
was the bigger picture for the future
was
oh yeah i mean it's this than opposed to
pills well look they they're
more appetizing more appealing yeah yeah
absolutely and and if people could feel
good about doing it instead of like you
know most people like i don't want to
feel the way i feel when i take these
pills
because you know you like you feel out
of yourself you feel very lethargic
well you know i was watching that thing
with john rubin right there crimes of
the century about the opiates
yeah and then those pain clinic medic
pain clinic that would
just open up everywhere and they were
they were killing people yeah
because they were just writing
prescriptions to get the pharmacies to
make the pills
but the woman who didn't need that
strength of
opiate but and the husband's like that
guy killed my wife
yeah that wouldn't have happened with
this but yeah yeah
i mean they they created addicts with
those opiates
you know because people can get those
you know
from any quack-ass doctor i mean and
that's what
why you see the problem is the way that
it is the family finally has pendulum
always been around and you know
no i went around when i was there the
other problem is some of these doctors
right they come out of
the universities and colleges they owe
that student loan the only way they can
get
out of it is if they go work for a big
practice
or you know the pharmaceutical companies
come and say hey
we need you to use this in your practice
and they get so much money for that half
the time
some of these guys don't even want to
prescribe that to you but they have to
and they cannot tell you hey go use
cannabis instead because then that
is is is a breach of their contract with
these pharmaceutical companies so
you know they're they're they're there
to help you but they're dealing death to
you at the same time
and it's all because of the student loan
that they get to pay off
and some of them get beyond that and now
they're living that lavish life and
they're just riding that
they're just sucking that titty all all
day
they ain't gonna let go of it they're
just gonna keep writing prescriptions
and
people od yeah they're in the car that
picture of the
two people in the car with their mouths
open asleep and a little kid in the back
like
inside yeah it's not saying did some of
them don't care that they
they've created these addicts they don't
care they're just getting paid money
hand over fist
some doctors give a [ __ ] but they're in
this
situation where they might not be able
to say anything because
they're all tied into these
pharmaceutical companies to some degree
right so is the pharmaceutical companies
with this now because i i can't imagine
that they
everybody would when wheat is legal that
the pfizers and all those places they
just kind of go all right
i think they got to be in the business
too i think they're waiting you know
like tobacco like alcohol like
every other big industry that that sees
the opportunity that they're going to
want to get into
and they'll find a way in uh
consumers that are are that make up the
industry now
they probably will not buy anything from
any of those companies that are backed
by by them because they you know these
folks these days do the diligence like
okay who owns this company
and if it's by any one of them
they're not they're going to stay away
from that brand if
if they can find out like okay well who
owns why would they stay away from it
because they don't trust them because
they don't trust them
they've let us down the wrong path for
so many years yeah yeah they they've
so many years so many deaths
related to all those companies right
coming into
this industry where you literally have
none
you know as it relates to
this having some sort of negative impact
and you know
or any side effects other than stupidity
yeah you're right am i starting to look
like a kid
you like the one from the plane a big
one look some people make mistakes
right on on anything or even without
drugs there's just some people that make
stupid mistakes and when stupid people
get high
and there's not smart people around them
they might you know cause themselves to
be injured or cause somebody else to be
injured we know that it's
it's not for everyone that can be
functional like
others right but it's literally
not caused any deaths in terms of
side effects like pharmaceutical would
or any other you know hardcore drugs so
as
a or even alcohol or even alcohol so so
the police now
i think their campaign is until they
figure out a better one
driving buzz there's still drunk driving
that's yeah damn
yeah so
all right
how do you how do you how would you
would have adapted for
when you pull somebody over that they
might be high than drunk
right yeah is that another test now you
have to worry about
not only do you have to worry about
drunk drivers and then people are under
the influence of
weed or any other form of drug but then
now which we didn't have so much then
you have mad mothers against drunk
drivers so they're monitoring everything
you know what you do before you know you
think there's a mother somewhere for a
drunk driver like there's a mom for it
there's another drunk driving out there
mothers for drunk driving
there's got to be you know mad mothers
you know some place out there yeah
against them
but they're they're damned if they're
doing the damned if they don't so if you
give the guy that's high a break
and he goes down two blocks later and
gets involved in an
accident well then you got everybody in
their mother against you because you let
them go
i don't know what kind of tests they're
giving people out in the field now
if you were a cop how would you by speed
or how would you know
you could see someone driving erratic
you say i'm gonna pull that person over
and it it'd be tough because you know
like there's stoners that are you know
highly functional
you know you wouldn't tell their their
stone you'd have to smell it to know
right like there's wheat in the car i
could smell it that's it exactly you
know you stop a car
for a vehicle called violation unless
they're stupid drunk and they're weaving
all over the place
when you get up to that driver you start
talking to them you can smell
wheat you can smell it right away
whether it's
billowing from inside the car out or if
it's on their breath
now people that have been eating stuff
you know i don't know because yeah you
can't really smell it i don't know that
you'd be able to smell anything
unless they farted yeah
so then you know there's got to be some
kind of probable cause take them out and
do
do other stuff with them but can they
walk the line of highly functional do
he'd run the line up and back yeah i
mean those those those uh
those tests don't work for for stoners i
have no idea what they're what they're
doing i mean they get
they'll give you a field test the same
way as if
you know they're you're getting i think
a dui
right um it it just it doesn't
work there that there's no way to to
to um you know judge how high this
person is by that test
it's ridiculous someone may have [ __ ]
up balance
doing some of those little tricks they
ask you to do
i couldn't pass one yeah and it's it's
it's an outdated test and it's pretty
ridiculous for for drunks yeah it works
because you know if
you're [ __ ] up it's it's going to show
with
with some of that but some people do
have [ __ ] up balance but do some
people do have [ __ ] up balance
not coordinated and you have to take
that into account and i think sometimes
some of the rookie officers don't know
the [ __ ] difference
when i was a when i was a kid i was
hardly around my mom and my mom would
trip over everything like a pattern in
the rug and [ __ ] everything so we're
at san fernando hardware
and upstairs is more sports and
downstairs is more of a hardware store
and they had a phone on the wall and my
grandmother says
uh frederick without you know the thing
my mom of course
they already tell her to look out for
the stairs my mom trips over the stairs
already going down
reaches out grabs the receiver on the
on the phone the pay phone and pull and
pulls the phone out with the wires and
everything still holding onto the black
thing trying not to fall off
the handset and just paint spilled and
the thing with the
[ __ ] thing came over the guy from the
hardware store is not like hey ma'am are
you all right he's like
looking at the [ __ ] did you rip this
thing
off the wall they didn't care about her
she went that leg behind her back over
the hill
i think it would be difficult to
to um to be drunk and have this
you have to pick one or the other yeah
you gotta you know yeah people drive
faster they're blacked out
i would say yeah unless you're like a
pro
at both yeah don't [ __ ] around don't mix
them
there's nobody that's that good i don't
think so all this stuff is all new to me
i'm sure there are people with high
tolerance for both didn't mix up but i'm
saying if if you're not
if you're not one of those don't [ __ ]
around okay
so let's see let's talk about tiger
woods
so tiger woods has had even before this
accident a lot of surgery
on his knees and his back fused neck
and the first time he got stopped he was
in the car
and he didn't even know where he was
going when when they pulled him over
middle of uh somewhere he thought he was
in orange county and he
thought he was i don't know what he
thought but he he would have just kept
driving like where he was where would he
have ended up you think
who knows he would he would
when does he come to the realization
that he doesn't know where he's going
right he was just driving because on a
flashback that'll happen
you know what i mean you'll like end up
somewhere like how the [ __ ] did i get
here
i think it was taking an ambient distal
silence that was that was pretty bad
ambient
i don't know ambient was bad man
if it's still out there because of the
side effects of yeah if
and if you drink with it i mean it's
it's it's a cocktail for
disaster so i would take ambien when i
was married
and i took a lot of things when i was
married but
my wife comes upstairs and i'm in a suit
upstairs completely dressed and she's
like
where are you going and i said i got a
show right now downstairs at the
wh where are you i'm in las vegas i
gotta what are you doing i got i got a
show
she goes no you don't i said hey ann i i
got to go i got a show like i've got to
be down there right now
and i didn't have a show and i was
upstairs took a shower
got dressed in a suit tied up and
everything where the [ __ ] you think i
would have went
to a show somewhere you would have
showed up to the venue like what are you
doing here today
and i didn't even [ __ ] uh even know
don't remember at all
i would not remember that's crazy
the side effects you know got you like
out of your mind right so
so tiger woods this one you're friends
with you're a sheriff the sheriff showed
up there
tiger woods this one severe damage to
his legs i think that
might have that could have happened over
there if he didn't get pulled over
because you're gonna eventually crash
but when you see something as a police
officer and it says that there's no
uh skid marks and no sign of breaking
that's he fell asleep that's what he
told first first thing come to mind
somebody falls asleep yeah
that that happens all the time yeah
because the only way you see skid marks
is if that guy um
woke up reacted to danger right
he didn't react to danger at all so he's
either in la la land or he's asleep
yeah yeah and people pass out all the
time i mean
you know it's important to have someone
else driving when
when you're [ __ ] i passed out and
wrecked
stone cold sober just the exhausting
hours long drive get there
fortunately never heard anybody it
happened once yeah didn't hurt
anybody it's just i mean that's
that's why for a long time [ __ ] in the
70s and 80s you had
truck drivers that had you know problems
with
with speed and meth and [ __ ] like that
because they got
these long hauls that they got to go on
and sometimes coffee just don't do the
trick and exhaustion
um plays in and vibrant remember
yeah and and so you know it's
it's know those yeah there's one there
there's
sleepy's the [ __ ] that puts you to sleep
and the [ __ ] that'll keep you up that
only works so long until your tolerance
is built
up to where like it ain't even working
no more you're just killing your [ __ ]
liver and your organs
that's that's a hundred percent true
remember jared told me something what
about these
these small bottles of uh environment of
our energy
yeah yeah what about those i mean no
what could be in that no one's come back
with anything about those yet
like of of of any crazy side effects
but like i i don't necessarily [ __ ] with
them because they're too sugary for me
a lot of it's a whole lot you know how
those things work
i just looked it up all right vitamin b6
folic acid
vitamin b12 sodium taurine
right let's see
glucorol malic acid some real crazy [ __ ]
caffeine
and uh yeah see so the caffeine
is the one that helps you ramp up with
some of that other [ __ ] you know
and for me like i can't do it [ __ ]
that's a this is [ __ ] this big it's
got all that [ __ ] in there all those
chemicals in it
man well you know they're supposedly
vitamins in there with it
supplements or whatever but it's
i don't know i i really don't [ __ ] with
those energy drinks so much
do you think that tiger woods is
addicted to prescription drugs in your
opinion as a
as a former police oh i have no idea i
don't know anything about it
i think he is he's got to be he's been
through a lot man
he's got to be in so much pain every
morning through that
because he did have surgeries before all
that like as a backstory unless he's
using
some cannabis i don't think he's i don't
think he's using
we're going to send someone something is
he going to prison yet
you know i gotta say you know it to me
that that's more a sign of prescription
pills than anything
because because because cannabis ain't
gonna just
make you go lights out unless you're
completely exhausted and you've smoked
yourself
[ __ ] you know to sleep and he wasn't
in that position
at that point because he was running
from one place to another
and it could be that you know because of
his back surgery that he's had and he's
been more actively playing
i mean he's a tough one because it's a
tough call you're not he's not an old
guy he's like
mid-40s yeah and he's had so much
brake play on the broken leg in 2008 and
his back infused
and he couldn't play and he came back
but those dudes like
two years or three years ago and the
masters they were chewing gum they were
chewing
cbd gum yeah and they started to
the golfers started to use there's a
video of that started feeling better on
that swing
phil mickelson and he takes the thing
out of alleged
he's the man he takes the thing out this
is how you know that's probably not
illegal so he takes the thing on he goes
like that that tells you right there
that it's not okay to do it because
they're going to test you because he
before he took it anyway
bro we try to cover like that and is cbd
the steroids for golfers
yes i don't think tiger would have won
the masters if you go those guys were
chomping out the whole weekend it's like
you don't think
they're not using it and chewing gum the
whole weekend it's not fair he's taking
cbds his swing is better
i got [ __ ] half a back
[Laughter]
but but i don't know if they've they've
used it
in golf i don't i think maybe basketball
i mean in every sport they're they
should
they're using every sport is using it um
you know you hear more more and more
athletes are
are uh going to that lane there was a
dude that had
tape like uh yeah medical tape medical
tape
and the tape was infused wow
and you put it on your you put it on
your pinky and and it works
and it works don't try to make your own
some duct tape at the house
alcohol
that might work though i think that
stuff it's everywhere so nobody can
start wrapping your
wrist or your hand and you and you feel
better oh yeah
like yeah the sports tape they've just
found a way to infuse the sports tape
like you see basketball players using
strips of it going down it almost looks
like a tattoo when you see it at first
but
then you notice it's just strips of tape
and
you know certain companies have figured
out a way to put the cbds
into those okay i think okay i think
that if they're going to make
guys and they're going to wear cbd that
they should wear tape that's green so
that you know that how about those
infused
uh not to defend either side but
those strips that you're talking about i
had both my knees replaced
and that was done 10 years ago yeah and
they started he said this
the physical therapist this is something
new and they started putting the
strip tapes like that you know so it
looked like a tattoo yeah geometric
lines on your
and i felt like a pro for a while yeah
tell me how they worked right
yeah yeah tell me how painful was
you can't do both at the same time you
want somebody i didn't do both the same
time i did it one at a time
and best thing i ever did the only thing
that was
painful most painful thing i've ever
been through therapy when you get up
there
like sit up sit up on the table and you
get up on the tables and
you're sitting there like that and your
legs up there while you just had knee
surgery your knees like this this being
the top of your knees folded
and then the therapist gets up there and
presses with all his weight
to try and break it to go back down and
it and it hurt
and there was a guy on the table next to
me and and the guy knew that i was a
company he said okay come on big boy
he said now my turn to get even so he
got up there he started doing it and i
started laughing at him and he's pushing
him down
and he finished and he walked away and
the guy next to me says how could you do
that that's the most painful [ __ ] i've
ever been through
i said i was too embarrassed to cry
because it was painful
that was the first the right knee
four or five months later i did the left
knee when he did the left knee i went up
there he said okay big boy you know
what's next i got up there my
my leg was like that it was flat first
time up and he says
how'd you do that he couldn't even get
his hand underneath my knee
and i said it's amazing what pain will
do for you
you already knew what to expect i knew
what to expect so while i was still
under
and i still had it i was still under the
medicinal
anti-pain i started working it right
away
and i didn't give a [ __ ] as much but so
when i got up there
no pain i'm not not like that but the
rest of it was easy
it wasn't painful at all man that's a
you must have a high threshold because
yeah yeah i know i have a
pain threshold but the best thing i ever
did
it makes it easy when you have things
like that available to you you know
i think i think the giants in san
francisco were having a section
for people that were they
were they using weed like do you think
that hey that would be
awesome if if in you know the the
the states that have cannabis legal
or decriminalized or whatever there is
would be a section for him like in the
staples center we adopted
that top balcony we just go there and it
was funny it was it used to be the
downstairs section
smoking section where the vip parking
sat right right right
and when 911 happened that whole [ __ ]
changed they they took
that downstairs space and they made it
that vip
part parking entrance and all that stuff
but
you know they they focused everything
now upstairs onto that
uh i think is the second the second
level balcony whatever
and we started smoking there it was like
maybe
10 15 of us that you know we were all
laker fans that we all
somehow got season tickets to the game
and we'd
congregate up in the smoking section and
we noticed that we weren't the only ones
smoking weed up there
and we were like okay we were always
constantly waiting
okay when is the the hammer gonna drop
on us when are the redcoats
coming and telling us we got to get the
[ __ ] out of here
they never did right and this was when
when
it was still new we had a prop 2 216 was
it or something like this
they didn't say [ __ ] and it built more
of a community of smokers there you see
more cannabis smokers than tobacco
smokers on that balcony today
and it was funny because then the lapd
starts coming in
and people were still smoking they did
not give a [ __ ] and and
the the crazy thing was that the lapd
didn't say
nothing to no one they were like okay
sir you got to go
you know they didn't boot no one out
unless you were being an [ __ ]
if you were being an [ __ ] you got to
go but
if you were being cool respectful and
you were smoking and
and you were you know are you sure there
were other they didn't go get
the [ __ ] out no army surplus i got
outfit no they were lapd's
and and uh man like they never bothered
no one to this day like that doesn't
sound like they're lapd to me
yeah but you know i've never bothered no
one i think
like what are you gonna do you're gonna
bust the whole top balcony of like what
a thousand to two thousand people in
there
possibly smoking you're gonna bust all
them that'd make some news
that would make some news and they would
look very [ __ ] up and i would imagine
that the staples center would be pissed
off
because that's you know a thousand
patrons that they're not getting money
from
i mean they got the initial ticket but
anything else like in merchandise or
beverages or any of that stuff you're
just
well they're not that i don't care any
agency that you know they're probably
brief before they go in there
hey don't bother yeah don't bother me
unless there's a fight
there's no reason to bother them it's
not that big a deal and no one did
who is the police officer who came up
with
hey why don't we get a list of
the guys who aren't the felons that we
still want
and let's send them a letter saying that
the washington redskins are inviting
them to a game
and they'll have a buffet and they get
to go to the thing go to the locker room
and they often show up at this hotel to
get their tickets
and the guys going to talk to them
they're all on the roof hey everybody
and then he says we'll we'll close the
doors and we'll bust them
we'll just it's a trap of stinger yeah
they didn't do that locally they
i don't remember them ever doing it
locally here but it's been done and
they've had it on the news it's a great
floor
they did they were they were finding
these guys like you said the
felons that they wanted to get finding
out where they might be stan or their
family is and they would send
oh you just won a 50-inch screen tv
blah blah blah all you got to do is this
and that
and some of them would fall for it
it's a genius move all you need to do is
see it once and then it's over you're
going to be like
this is the [ __ ] it's like that [ __ ]
they did in boston yeah i haven't seen
the way the police works uh in uh oh
in the in the top five let's say
of smokers um who
who are your top five because uh
in seeing willie nelson and knowing how
much those dudes
woody house and those guys like you know
and snoop and yourself
yeah give me the five highly functional
cheech
uh yeah they told me chong told me that
if cheech eats an edible
he is out of his mind smoking it is okay
but
for some reason the edibles yeah if
because it's tolerance
if if it's something you don't do then
it affects you crazy when you have some
something that's you know dosed higher
than what you normally take
yeah it's going to affect you and some
people are you know they don't function
well off of it but like
the five guys that that that um
i know like that are you know they can
function off
most things is uh obviously snoop
wiz khalifa um my partner berner i'm
sure you've heard of him
um and let's see there there's so many
others uh like
willie nelson i mean this that dude was
like
a king in in in the in the [ __ ] i think
he
does more edibles now um and less
smoking as he's gotten older right
but yeah how much energy you smoke yeah
it might and you know depending on how
active you stay
too you know like physically active um
what's the best way to to ingest it
somebody said burning was the worst way
i mean
i guess so because i mean you know
you're ingesting smoke in your lungs but
i mean you know it's
it's clean you guys want a beer you want
a beer no i'm good i'm all right you
don't smoke do you want drink do you
sometimes i'll take one yeah yeah um
yeah yeah but but i think people people
are um
they feel like it's it's cleaner to
ingest it
or drink it you know in a tincture or
something right
than the lungs if you don't want to have
any so-called lung damage which
you know we haven't seen too many people
come up with that
if i were and i'm not but if i were
i wouldn't do the the smoke because i do
have lung damage
you know they've cut a chunk of my lung
yeah on already so i'd be afraid
yeah uh to do anything yeah so like if
you got any
problems with your lungs most of those
folks
lean towards the edibles or whatever you
know it
all depends on what type of edibles you
like you know how they say if you
if you boil uh vegetables that they
lose their vitamins yeah
if you smoke does it at some point lose
its potency because you're kind of
burning and
i don't think so i don't think so
because you're ingesting
that thc in your system is do you know
it gets into your blood system either
way it's just
one gets in a little bit faster than the
other i don't think you could be a
smoker
you have to be a person that eat because
you you know you got too many latinos
around you
you know smoking is loud right and if
you're a paranoid person
or or you're someone that is constantly
in thought you know where you overthink
things just naturally
yeah smoking um smoking
is is is a challenge because you know
like you're smoking and
if you think a lot already it's going to
enhance that right
and the fact that the smoke is like
it's like a smoke signal right it's
someone can pinpoint where you that they
could smell you and they could see you
and that'll add to your paranoia right
so you know folks that think like that
yeah
they're probably better off doing an
edible because you don't get it's a
different
type of feeling you still get high
but it's it's it's not that same
paranoid type of feeling because like
yeah smoking weed is loud doing edible
is not loud at all
you know it's it's very you know
intimate to yourself
right you know people can't see the
smoke they can't smell
and you know any of it you could ingest
like i think i had a gummy with these
guys i smoked a little bit i had half
and then the other half but you don't
have to eat the whole thing after you
take
miniature whatever or pieces but
there's more control in that yeah than
in
yeah and smoke for sure for sure you
know
um you could you know there's people
that can take one or two puffs and put
it down
um but then there's other people that
want to just continuously smoke that
[ __ ] so they can't put it down and
you know that's when you know if you
don't have a lot of tolerance
you can get really smashed whereas this
you know you know that there's
only so many milligrams per per
um serving which is i had a sister
i still have her i had a sister that was
really she was going through some
troubled medical issues
and she just told me how you doing
and she just told me she was fine but
she had been [ __ ] up somebody gave her
some brownie
and didn't realize she ate the whole
thing she said oh it was ugly that's
what it
always happened don't eat the whole
thing
don't eat the whole thing all right i'm
not feeling anything oh
listen so if you if you eat some cookie
or
thing whatever and you say i don't feel
anything
do not eat more i'd say wait about 15
more minutes
and then if you don't feel something
then maybe take another
another one or a half of one or
something like that because that's
people are you know are impatient they
want it
that fast that's and and with with uh
edibles especially ones that are you
know properly dosed
it's going to take some time but it's
going to get there
but if you know your tolerance and you
know how much you could take it you know
what it is
to get you there then you take as many
as
you need to to get there but folks that
are like
new to it yeah when you think
okay it's 10 minutes and i don't feel
nothing wait another 10 minutes
and if you don't feel anything then take
another one
but chances are because that's where
everybody goes wrong that first 10 15
minutes
oh man i don't feel nothing completely
did they take
one or two more and then they're over
the top so it's important to be patient
okay
let's let's come up with a scale of so
these are
um 0.02
uh milligrams right right so per cookie
um what what does that mean in a one to
ten what is
o2 is probably hardly hardly any yeah
it's like a
almost like a micro dose right two
milligrams
yes two milligrams per cookie
it's a hundred actually 20 milligrams
per cookie and between
uh that dude's all [ __ ] up man
[Laughter]
yeah i think what he was saying there's
20 cookies right in there
fire your first day ten cookies 20
milligrams a piece right so like
a hundred a hundred and total total
some people will eat that get the [ __ ]
out who's that
that guy is on god can you imagine man
if it wasn't so sugary he could eat that
whole [ __ ] thing right but that
because they're so
you know there's sugar in there you
don't want to eat that whole [ __ ] you
know there and there's some edibles that
have
100 milligrams in the one serving
so if you wanted that quick punch these
ain't the ones to do
these are the ramp up you know what i
mean there are
like chocolate bars and other gummies
that like are highly dosed
that you could take if you want to ramp
up fast but these are the slow ramp
you know um what would somebody start
with uh like
you could start with like you know that
looks like like someone that that's
new they could start off with one or two
i know
a friend and you know you're not a
police officer anymore so you're not
under the
i don't imagine the thin blue light
whatever no no no no no i don't want to
throw it
throw anybody look at my mace right
somebody very close to me a friend
got some of the chocolate yeah
and broke off a square and she ate it
and she said she felt ugly she
just stopped once she had never touched
it i think that's a woman that thing has
a woman thing with chocolate i'm ugly
nobody likes me i think that's probably
just them could be
or that that one piece you know of of
that
chocolate bar was dosed with a lot
because some people
you know will dose each piece
very high well the normal person
wouldn't know yes
so somebody's just starting um so let's
just say you had a chocolate bar this
big right
roughly about that big yeah someone can
dose
that whole thing with let's just say 500
milligrams
and each piece is 100 milligrams
it makes up that that chocolate bar
right so
it could be that you know they gave her
something that had
too much she's a bit of more chicken
shoes right that's right she was gone
that's exactly the right thing
she asked her hey how many servings yeah
and and
you know you might not you might look at
it and say oh this is just a little
piece how could this
show but it's 10 milligrams of a good i
think 10 milligrams on those
yeah those gummies 10 milligrams
for a start that's perfect you know for
a start that's perfect 10
20 might be a little bit much a lot but
uh
do you know 10 yeah for a first timer
they could definitely deal with
it like running like the more you do it
the higher tolerance you get or do you
always
well it depends on the frequency you
take it right so like let's just say you
take
one cookie per day eventually you'll get
to
maybe i gotta take two to feel it now
because you've built up your tolerance
but
may take some time
[Laughter]
i don't know man this thing right here
i don't you know this thing's still here
i don't do a lot of edibles to be honest
with you you know
you smoke i smoke more yeah and you and
you are highly functional oh most
definitely highly functional he could he
can
be high and functional and highly
functional amazing
although all the guys on your podcast
yeah i've trained them
you know top notch it's like being with
the [ __ ] marijuana
green berets that's right
we already i'm just a private those
dudes were green berets
special forces special forces seals they
they do it all
functions we smoke more in the morning
than most people do all day all day
we'll smoke more by 9 a.m that most
people do all day
nothing no slurred speech no what were
we talking about how about the time i
was always drinking like hey crap
what are we talking about okay bruce lee
bruce lee how the [ __ ] is that
bruce lee but
yeah it's very impressive to see you
guys do that because it's
i guess it would be like somebody uh the
tour de france
well i think that could make those old
stereotypes you know that they used to
have for stoners were based off of
you know folks that didn't want to do
[ __ ] you know this generation of
of smoker stoner advocate um
you know enthusiasts whatever you want
to call them connoisseur
um we all are trying to break those
stereotypes
you know there's there's more for us to
do these days [ __ ] come up with tour
de france
hey they don't just ride bikes these
guys ride tour bikes
yeah where they wear helmets and their
shoes click into the pedals
think about it right in every sport now
there's
a world champion that has smoke some
weed
somewhere along the line michael phelps
what 16 gold medals
he's a weed head yeah you know
um and there's a quarterback for usc
that uh marinovich yeah
marijuana he didn't want to play
football yeah
his father made him appreciate that you
know i played football yeah he
his father made him his father made him
play and he just wanted to smoke some
weed
and he ended up homeless and yeah
smoking too much weed and not doing
anything you've got
to add some edibles maybe yeah be
functional right
but look you got guys like matt barnes
saying you know like
that he's he's been a weed smoker
through his high school
through his uh collegiate career and all
during his pro career
you know i mean you you have guys that
that are now
um boxers that admitted to like mike
tyson
was smoking you know throughout his
career he never smoked during training
camp but he smoked
you know he was a smoker i mean he's
he's not one of the guys who just
came in and started smoking too now i
understand why he was so mean in the
ring
he needed to get some more weeds well he
told us that he
never fought while he was high or
trained while he was high except for one
fight which was with
andrew gulotta and he said in that fight
he never felt more
focused in in than any other fight like
he actually broke the dude's uh
he think he broke his uh his cheekbone
and he broke a part of his back with a
body punch
because he was that focused imagine had
he been high
for all his fights like that because
people will tell you that train if
they're athletes you know on on that
whether whether they're you know
beginners in the middle or they're pro
athletes
that you know but based on their
tolerance sometimes it gives them hyper
focus
like their workouts extend longer that
they feel like they can
work themselves exactly the way they
need to because they're focused on it
they're you know
when they're not high you want to just
sort of get it over with
because it's like a chore instead of
locking in
and uh i don't think i don't think gil
understands what i'm looking at from the
side
the potential in saying that you could
be better on
it and sometimes some people you don't
you don't get diminished
yeah because you're always looking like
you're trying to figure out where you
can get somebody
in your head no i'm sitting there saying
we're gonna solve the nightstalker in a
month
right yeah i mean you know because there
was so much misinformation on cannabis
back in the day you know what i mean um
so people looked at it like oh this is
the gateway this
is what starts me off a [ __ ] dark
path and
and this and that and for some it it did
but i don't know man it's it's choices
that people make
not this particular thing you know the
gateway for someone is
their badass friends with badass
influences or their badass parents with
badass influences
or the bad choices you make on your
[ __ ] own
because there's people with upbringing
that you know they had everything
but they made their their own bad choice
they were their own gateway
it wasn't this or that or them
it was the self you know what i mean and
most people don't
ever admit to that they'll always blame
it on something else and
you know so for people to you know say
that weed was a gateway that was a whole
lot of bad information
and now you know there's there's
different information out there and you
see more and more people
you know that are very functionable at
what they do
um locking in you see using it as a tool
to lock in
they use it for a lot of autism and they
use it for oh yeah
yeah yeah i mean there's a lot of great
usage now and
uh you know it's great to see those
stories
happening as opposed to what we used to
see with the anti-propaganda
what's the other one tourette's
tourettes okay you know they move around
they get take it straight and say some
crazy [ __ ] yeah
um you know he worked on the
nightstalker right yeah the thing
well um if richard ramirez had been on
this you think it had been
would you guys would have found each
other
he was using wheat but he was using yeah
but then he started using cocaine that's
when he really started getting um
crack no mess no straight coat cocaine
cocaine to the brain made him insane
yeah
it was crazy [ __ ] how he was going to
the cecil hotel
after some of the [ __ ] that he was doing
you know in bloody clothes and no one
said a [ __ ] thing to him there
did they they saw him in his underwear
well i i don't know you said this last
time i think i don't know i know he kept
his clothes
check this out inside the greyhound bus
deep in the locker
so i don't know if he was changing in
the great bus depot or he was chained
you know
it it only seems natural for me to
believe that he'd go
and put on we call it his kill kit
change clothes there
and then when he's done go back and get
out of him right away anyway
and that's why he's stunk you know they
had this pungent odor
just imagine yeah you never cleaned them
right never clean them just
water them back up put them in the
locker but then also if somebody a
police officer went to the hotel and
said i want to get into this room
and you go in there and he's not there
but you wouldn't find anything
incriminating in there no
there so here we go that's not our guy
yeah
[ __ ] hey right he had people scared
shitless this guy that's what we were
talking about
yeah where were you on that so you're
probably a little kid i was a little kid
at that point
but i'll tell you what you know sooner
or later he
anyone that knew anything knew sooner or
later he'd run into the wrong
neighborhood
and he was going to get [ __ ] up and
sure enough he did
the thing i don't i don't get which is
still crazy is that he
i guess he had to know everybody i don't
know if they knew they were looking for
him
he didn't know we were looking for him
until the day he got caught so
that morning even with the fear like i
was in the valley and all around here
you know you felt it
your parents felt that he might strike
and still he did he didn't say like oh
[ __ ] i'm gonna take
some couple of years after this he's
still delivered he was
bold damn guy was bold
daring you guys to catch him you'd only
had some cookies
yeah [ __ ] the real deal what do you
think sent him on the way that that
his his uncle sean when he did that hurt
his wife
killed his wife he asked me he asked me
why do you think i'm i am the way i am
why do you think i turned this way
i told him i don't know if i knew that
i'd be a doctor making a lot more money
than i am as a cop
i know my job so he asked you that why
do you why do you think i'm the way that
i am so did he not know no he didn't
know
you know and that's probably one of the
biggest questions i get asked today
uh for people all over the world doctors
you know why
what do you think oh no
my job was just to gather the facts i
ain't no [ __ ] is it a traumatic
experience you think it's some trauma
it's brown or just bad
problems he says he was beat as a kid
uh yeah but that his dad would
beat his ass and laugh and then he'd go
sleep in the cemetery
because it was peaceful there and i said
god daddy how do you do that [ __ ] didn't
that something
scare the [ __ ] out of you some people
are just born with a bad gene
you know what i'm saying i don't know
because that's people's was he born like
that did he get like that you know was
he a subject
i don't know my job was just to yeah
could you imagine how [ __ ] scared
you'd be
if you took your old lady to the
cemetery to go there be private and
you're looking rich ramirez is [ __ ]
lame right
by a graveyard and all black clothes
comfortable
hey what's up you need a couple give me
a cookie give me a cookie
you never bother my hair but
he liked that he told him that he he
liked to see the fear in other people
yes he got off on that yeah he got off
on
what the people would look their faces
would look like when they saw him
this is a sick individual you know when
you get off on something like that
so it's charles manson they said when
charles manson was a young kid he he was
in school he got
kids to do something they didn't want to
do which is what he did over there he
had already been powerless
that was his power yeah a master
manipulator right
some people come along you know and and
and know how to connect with people
whether it's
on some good [ __ ] or whether it's that
right cult leader you know i'm leading
you to the grave [ __ ]
jim jones was another one or uh jim
jones
yeah with guyana um
some of the some of those uh what was
that other guy um
heaven's gate oh yeah yeah and then dave
koresh
applewood yeah and they all had they all
had this this
this way that they talked and were able
to connect and manipulate people when
they found
we've had impact with you know with what
we're trying to indoctrinate these
people with
you know and it's it's it's it's a
powerful tool man if if you're someone
that has that
um but how do kids learn it like my
daughter would go crazy we went to a
store she didn't want to be and she'd
look around she like little [ __ ] toys
in here
and throw herself on the ground and
you'd have to take her out because she'd
be screaming and then when she got in
the car she'd be
quiet like kids kids in a weird way got
a
a sense of how you react to this their
their certain
patterns right like they know like kids
are observant right
they see another kid crying in front of
their parents to get their way with
something and if they got parents that
cave in
oh maybe ought to try that
there was a female comedian i want to
say her name was debbie gutierrez
yeah and she used to talk about her
little kid you know and mommy and
mexicans don't play that [ __ ] start
beating the [ __ ] out of right there in
the store
oh yeah yeah and when you would see a
kid get hit in the store you'd go oh
[ __ ] been grabbing on pulling them i was
there a car
because i think it's like maybe a latino
thing they walked in front of the car
and there was a little bit of some water
before you got to the curb
and probably the kid was like three
walking and the mom
grabbed it by the grab him by the arm
and picked him up over the water
with by the arm yeah yeah
i mean you won't you won't
people don't expose themselves as much
as they used to because
now everybody's got a [ __ ] phone but
yeah that used to be a
horrible thing my mom just used to pinch
she pinched my arm pinch my ear and just
say whatever else
right yeah just wait till we get home
and then she
beat me when i got home yeah you know
back in the day you could discipline
your kids and not have to worry about
if you're going to get reported for that
yeah you know but now you have
you know the schools like their protocol
is to
tell the kids if anything happens
you call the police on your parents if
you had a kid that
was having some you know they go like
adderall and all that stuff
if the kids out there in the they're
giving them
pills to focus would you switch to this
would you
as a parent would you say like maybe
absolutely if if uh if it
could treat what what the ailment what
if i gave one of these cookies to a
little kid
could i go to prison probably yeah
that's not dangerous
infusion you're not a doctor infused
with cannabis yes
cbds um that don't have any thc in it
i mean i know that there's parents
giving their kids cbds now
to treat them for epileptic seizures and
they're some of them are even using full
spectrum which is cbd with a little bit
of thc
and it it causes that full spec that's
what they call full speed yeah both
yeah and um some of these kids have
lessened
with with their their seizures and stuff
like that there was a big story on
on this like maybe two years ago so
we do know that yeah there's there are
parents that are buying
cbds for their kids maybe not full
spectrum depending on what the ailment
is
but yeah i mean i don't i don't believe
that is against the law as long as it
doesn't have thc in it
you know or there's some sort of doctor
doctors written thing saying that
yes she is prescribed this he or she has
prescribed this um but yeah no i
wouldn't i wouldn't give
any kids any of these ones right here
but you know it's almost like when
flintstone vitamins came out
that you could give your kid you know
who thought of that let's make a
let's make a vitamin look like fred
flintstone
so the kids would be like oh i want it i
want to take some of that
because it's a vitamin that looks like
or the gummy bear yeah
yeah that that was a thing in the
cannabis industry um
that you could not have a child you
could not have a product that appeals to
kids so that they open that bag or
package
thinking that it's a candy or or
something that is made for kids
you know that's why they sort of you
know put a put a regulation on
some of the visual presentation of some
of these products to make sure that you
know
and that it cannot be mistaken for uh
for uh something for a child as opposed
to an adult i think some of those things
were a bit of using meth some of the
some of the medicines that they used to
sell even in the store
uh geritol or those pills
i think they were like a little bit of
speed jared's all were those like gel
caps
for old people yes wasn't geritol to go
to sleep though
or when no no that was an energy energy
yeah oh really
geritol cherokee i just take geritol
high school during baseball season a
[ __ ] good day
i'm jared so that was that was
considered
okay so that would be considered a male
enhancement
that was all about one person i would be
like this what's wrong with it [ __ ] i'm
just ready to go
that was good on time man yeah yeah that
that was considered the first male
enhancement i
i think so right if you total soup if
that's basically we should say turtle
soup
would make your have they made one of
those for these yet when i feel like
i would imagine they're coming
it's probably they're coming probably a
cbd [ __ ] ring too probably
you wet it like trunks
[Laughter]
with cbd full spectrum on your wheels
right there your all your little cbd
back there
[ __ ] swimming just forever the
[ __ ] lake where is it going [ __ ] i
don't know
i don't know he's coming back he feels
good [ __ ] swim up and back and
uh what's that one over there
[ __ ] have a sue or whatever this
would be like have a suit
i think i'll be pretty good put on a
thong and come out looking like a churro
[Laughter]
who wrote this book uh a guy by the name
of glenn
uh
glenn if my name was glenn i wouldn't
even [ __ ] answer in school
i would just just be baking i'd wear
glenn i'd i'd wear cowboy hats
glenn martin cowboy and martin he was a
he's a retired lapd cop his dad was a
glendale cop
yeah it's a crazy cover right there
it is a uh book on the night stock
it's a crate it
hey so when he when he was running
around i would imagine
gun sales oh went way up went way the
[ __ ] up it's called
satan's summer in the city of angels
there was that other there was that
other one too uh what was they calling
him
but he was much out he was after he was
like which one golden state killer
nah he was in los i think he was in los
angeles south side slayer
yeah oh [ __ ] yeah who was a south side
slayer
he was killing uh prostitute prostitutes
yeah that they call the grip wait is
that also
also known as the grim reaper no that's
another guy this is a south side slayer
the grim reaper was in south central too
right yes he came after when he was
discovered yeah this guy was killing
strawberries
out in the street out in south central
and he was using a
22 caliber for some people who wouldn't
know you know
like what a strawberry prostitutes with
a crack habit
yeah that's what they that's a
strawberry
that's you have to go with both you
can't just be
that's that's what we call them
strawberries strawberries
why because what do you know reuben
but grapes not grapes are not dystrophic
for some reason strawberries yeah i
don't know how that happened
it just sort of happened yeah i don't
either but you know it's just what we
called them you know what
the word did gil say uh what did he just
say around he's already hitting me
well you knew the vernacular of the
detective yeah he said strawberries yeah
he said strawberry yeah
and that's what you know that they're
was the southside slayer latino
no it was black nice yeah they never did
catch him
i don't think they called they arrested
one guy thinking it was him
thinking it was him and
one of the agencies i'm not going to
mention which one but it wasn't ours
they got the ballistics wrong and they
had to kick the guy loose
and it screwed it up that's the case man
how come they're not talking about that
because they don't want to talk about
that that's a bad ball drop right there
yeah so i mean because that's like
someone who never got caught
on a war they might have gotten caught
and they at least
someone but yeah what years were that
seven earnings
that was uh late 80s late 80s early 90s
right
yeah yeah or before the 90s because we
had just finished
that's right 88 89 yeah i had that
they i was so pissed off because it
wasn't my case
but i was watching these guys and they
said at one time he changed calibre
a gun and they said well it's not the
same guy this is a different caliber gun
and i'm sitting there telling him you
know you didn't learn anything i mean
right
with a nightstalker thing you know it
doesn't happen about that dude like if
you use
like a guy wouldn't use two guns like
he's only gonna get it so yeah exactly
uh i'm gonna say ricky ross was the guy
that the
freeway yeah and so they got him but
they had to let him go
and because like i said somebody messed
up on the ballistics
and still so you don't you don't hear
about him anymore but he hasn't hit
anymore either
so it stopped yeah i remember one of the
last descriptions of
he that someone supposedly saw him he
had like a
raiders hat and a gray sweatshirt that
was the last image i remember seeing of
him on tv
that someone could describe of someone
who was in the area when one of these
you know so they had a person's gut they
had a make let's say
they they had an idea yeah i remember
hearing about that
how many people did he kill a ledge
they had them at least four or five of
them
madness you don't really become
something until it's over 10.
yeah but who knows he could have done
more over 10. no one ever called them
i mean caught him and and what about the
grim reaper
i don't know how many did but there were
some lapd
in our area and there's still some that
are unsolved that could be him but
there's not enough evidence to link them
so it's always when one of those guys
talks to their celli
if they're locked up which is good
police work right
then they put a cop dressed up as like a
uh
they've done that they've done that yeah
in the rossos case the female deputy
they got killed
in long beach where they where they put
somebody in there they put somebody
they got a tst bus a regular
transportation bus
because they knew the two guys that were
involved in it were in the joint on
pearl violation
so they made a loop they had to make an
appearance so they got a bus
and they filled it up with about 15
prisoner but not one of them was a
prisoner
they were all tatted undercover cops
from different departments different
agencies
uh and the guy that was on board the bus
in uniform like a transportation guy
was actually a homicide comp the bus was
wired they were wired
they got them down here and so they
brought them down a cj when they got
them
irc they put them all in cells they did
these guys talked about everything they
got it all
and they not only did were they able to
convict them they got their mother
because she was helping him out after
one of the guy's mother was helping him
out after the fact
and so it was a why would a dude what's
the philosophy behind like you know
somebody's gonna talk because they're
scared
what can happen and then you think as a
release for them they need to talk to
somebody but they think they're
talking to somebody they could trust
exactly you know they just
you take your tent nothing ventured
nothing gained so
the guy that masterminded this thing
brilliant
brilliant detective good friend of mine
he put the whole thing together you
don't want to say his name
competition no no no no mark lillian
field
yeah he he did he did uh my wife knew
if anything ever happened to me insists
on department i want mark lillian filled
on a case
he's a brilliant investigator listen i
don't want to say anything about
a level of
law enforcement in los angeles but
in the charles manson case
a reporter found some clothes down
because the reporter said hey
how long would it take me to leave this
house and change my clothes
and they go on the guy's in the car and
the guy's changing clothes they go pull
over and
over the side they found
the clothes down there but a reporter
found it
not pdal
[ __ ] happened but i mean you know
they're out there were there any
sheriffs there no not a that's not the
same
they did we had one of the cases but
primarily it was
the other the blue the guys in blue they
thought
close over the side of the road there
it's a different style of training for
them
you know when you think about it
sheriffs they they got to do the
the two years as deputies in the prisons
dealing with
with people you know dealing with uh
criminals
right off top so when they get in so
when they get into the
to the patrol cars and they're doing
they know how to deal with someone
right off the top they won't be
intimidated as opposed to a lapd
officer who has been through a scenario
style training as opposed to
you know training with with guys like
right there
on on the spot training how to diffuse
the situation with the felon or whatever
you know how the lapd is hiring people
now let me see put your arm out here
right am i right about that like they
they have the the academy
they they they have the academy style
training which
you know it's training but it's not the
same as you being
in united scenarios
and i'm not bad-mouthing i'm not doing
it i'm just saying
as a deputy you get sent to the jail
for the most part one guy out of the
class gets to go straight to patrol
he's the honor cadet everybody else goes
to the jail and you stay in the jail
anywhere from
two and a half to five six years wow so
you're gaining
experience in dealing with the other
element the bad guys
and knowing some of these and these guys
can talk you right out of your shorts
that's their life in there they know the
business and you tell them hey
you're going to be talked right out of
your shoes so that that's the way it
that's what it is so when you get out on
the streets
you have a little bit of this and you
have
a lot of that telling you be careful to
switch yours
a good training program i don't think
anybody knows that and
and i think anybody knows that the
sheriffs have to go different training
that's why they're in prison for two to
six four or six years maybe
so a gangster when he sees a sheriff
lapd coming up he knows he can kind of
talk to him and
maybe possibly intimidate a new guy
but when a sheriff rolls up you know
none of that [ __ ] happened okay listen
you just said that and right now i grew
up here
i did not think of it like that like
that
you guys were so highly trained in the
lapd was up in
behind dodgers stadium uh you know
running and doing that stuff
the six years in a prison or in jail is
and then being on the street you just
feel like you're already covered as
opposed to
being lapd maybe and then you become a
patrol officer with
with another partner that's got a scary
[ __ ] out of people
for new officers how do they really
prepare for
you you're learning all this
inner relationship between bad guys and
good guys you're learning on the streets
most of that is learned in custody and
in a controlled environment
so when you get out there and you get
somebody working with you telling you
now okay now this is what you look for
out here you already know how to talk to
people a little bit better
yeah so it works out and i'm not
listening i think that's just
no this is a better way to be a and
that's why you know rookies
from the lapd they go in with veterans
to like you know they're
holding their hand through some of this
process right as they're gaining
their footsteps in you know what i mean
and you could see why some situations
get a little bit unraveled because
some of these guys just don't know how
to deal with
[ __ ] on the street i think
that's i think that says a lot about it
yeah they don't doesn't negate either
department from having bad guys inside
right no but yeah and so it is but i
think these guys are
in a case where somebody's been an
officer for you know a year and a half
and when they pull you over they got a
little more aggressive or
they're afraid oh yeah you know what
you're dealing with like if you're if
you're a person that comes from that
life you know what you're dealing with
the difference
you will not [ __ ] around with the
sheriff the same way you [ __ ] around
with the lapd
now he just said it's a man he just i
had no idea about that he just said it
but it's been recorded it's been on
other broadcasts where you talk to
people from the area
and they'll sit there and admit we won't
[ __ ] around
that's insane they may not like neither
of them
but they'll give more lip to a lapd
officer
and they will give zero lip to a sheriff
because the sheriff will [ __ ]
jack you the [ __ ] up no intimidation
on the part of that shock before you
came in i had no idea i've dealt with it
first had many times that's true right
sure did you know reuben i didn't know
yeah that their whole get down their
whole protocol
is different it's controlling the
situation
you know you are not going to intimidate
not one of them
these are the ones that put flares out
especially the ones that have had
military training before they were
sheriffs
you're even more [ __ ] if you try to
lip off there
you know that that's the thing with no
idea you know that's that's the
difference between some of the lapd
guys some of them are military guys so
they come in with
with some different kind of knowledge on
how to deal with people but
some of the other guys that are you know
maybe former jocks
right their colleges didn't make it into
the sport they wanted to but they're fit
enough to be a cop you know
the easier way to get in than the
sheriff way is the lapd
way right whoa and it is just and
they're both
great departments but different types i
don't want to say nothing bad about them
and they say something but
all chicano that's 100 chicano but but
they're
uh it's good and then that's the way
you need them both so some of them
within both
um agencies some of them you don't need
because some of them aren't good people
didn't you and i talked
about the civil unrest and and there was
a department downtown la that
had uniforms out with no badge or no
identification oh yeah was that you and
i what's up
we had a similar conversation they were
dressed up i think you might see them
either all in black those guys were like
all in green but with no markings
of any kind right and they would snatch
you up
and throw you in a van and drive off
yeah i don't know what department that
that is
different i don't know what is that like
a secret menu like i don't know what
department it is
i hope they found those people because
it's a trip
they didn't they did it in portland
everywhere they show up just all in
black
yeah and those might have been homeland
guys
possibly private security yeah that's
what they had up in portland yeah
homeland security guys did i introduce
you guys now we just started talking
all right well i love gilman that's my
man
i don't know why you're drinking very
like it's you guys after i'm still
talking
in the summer
man my hero be real uh from the
wonderful group cypress hill
who wrote rap star that should i did the
michael jackson listen to that song he
should have
you [ __ ] still be alive
[Laughter]
the chorus and in my part send dog wrote
his piece and stuff and mugs did the
music everybody you know did their thing
i had the idea in my head for like five
years before i
we actually you know put it down these
guys are brilliant man
but uh i just wish i would have been
younger to listen
to the stuff that you i and i kept
telling my wife i said but only i was i
was gone all last week
and i kept telling him i gotta call my
son he'll he'll light me up on this
stuff
i i'm sure and now i i'm sorry i didn't
oh no worries
what an honor is never too late yeah how
did you find the the
i was looking at a little bit of the
stuff about you that the nasal lead when
you sing
that that was uh you know it wasn't
necessarily
accident but you know i wasn't rapping
in this voice in our early demos right
and it was told to me by mugs
and you know like hey man we gotta do
something about your voice
otherwise you're going to have to write
raps for senddog
because i was i was you know pretty
decent at writing
at the least right and uh but my
delivery needed
work and so we were big fans of this
this rapper named ramel mlz out of new
york
and he was also an artist like uh you
know he created
paintings and different works of art
aside from what he did as a as a wrap
how come i never heard of that guy
because he's
old school old school like have you ever
seen this uh uh
that that movie wild style he's in that
movie his name is ram lz and he has like
a couple parts in there
and he did this thing with his voice
where
one minute he'd be rapping like this and
blah blah blah and then all of a sudden
he was way up here doing some [ __ ] like
that right
and i you know i thought that was unique
no one else was kind of doing that
and when when mugs told me hey we need
to do something about your voice
i was thinking okay let me try what ram
z does wow
and and the first song that we did was
real estate
which is on our first album and when we
heard how that came out with me pitching
my voice up
we adopted that tone and started doing
it on the other
other songs and they kind of worked out
and then send dog
figured out another tone that he could
put on top of that to like
you know sprinkle it with something
different and that's how it came up it
was like
either come up with the voice or i'm
writing the songs
yeah it took me a minute to get used to
it too because like at first i thought
you know they weren't going to like it
because it was really high pitched and
nasally and [ __ ] like that and nobody
really was doing that except for
maybe the beastie boys they had a
similar style tone
but the the the the cadence and flow
were slightly different and
you know we were talking street [ __ ] and
they're talking party boy stuff so that
was
a major difference in what we were but i
took a chance
and then i had to learn how to do it
live because doing it in the studio was
different
getting in front of a hundred or a
thousand or ten thousand people
controlling your voice to to to do that
and it took me like three four years to
get that right but
yeah i had to learn to like it everybody
else liked it but me i was like are you
[ __ ] kidding me you like that you
want me to rap
okay [ __ ] it if that's what's going to
be on the record
and then i learned to like it and use it
to my advantage
well you know if you ever want to do a
album of slow songs
you could just use your normal voice
yeah but the other [ __ ] would expect the
high
i'll use my kevin slow james voice but i
mean
an incredibly unique sound and uh
an amazing i remember that [ __ ] came out
i was still doing i was still in the
clubs
i was doing arsenio and i would take my
music on the road and it was almost like
taking your friends with you on the road
because i should suck out stay in an
apartment or a condo all day than you
and
we didn't know we didn't know you were
listening to our [ __ ] like that
if we had known would have reached out
way sooner
than we eventually did listen i love
kiss when they
every time they open their shirt in the
show they go you wanted the best you got
the best
the hottest man in the world kiss i
think that's okay
but who are you trying to get crazy with
that's it don't you know i'm loco
beats that that's the number one because
when i heard that [ __ ] i used to play in
the
clubs and the rooms who wrote that you
did yeah
yeah yeah that that was uh you know it
was a song about being crazy or or the
chorus was about being crazy so we
needed something
to intro the song properly and it shows
mugs saying it on the video but it's
actually
me saying it i don't know why we did it
like that but we thought it would be
cooler for mugs to say it right
and then go into senenai because we were
always
we were always flipping [ __ ] like that
like so like if you look at killer man
right the video for kill a man
um can you put it up it shows send dogs
i mean it shows mugs doing send dog's
part
in terms of uh his part in the verse
like so there's a part where sendog
on the album says i'm ignoring all the
dumb [ __ ] cause nothing is coming from
it i'm not gonna waste no time [ __ ]
around my gats humming
humming coming at you sorry that i had
to get you
it shows mugs saying that in the video
but it's actually send dog
saying it on the album and we used to do
wow [ __ ] like that just to you know flip
people out
you know like are you sure like the
jackson five they didn't let anybody
else see because they weren't
they were like nice b12s or niacin like
no one nobody in the jackson five
at least the male singers were anywhere
near
i think the talent level of michael j
maybe jermaine yeah i mean they were
they were good as a group but like he he
stood out amongst them you know
he was different you don't think you're
let's say if you were
like you had four other brothers five
but four other brothers and you were the
singer
you go to albera street and people love
you throw pennies quarters at you right
there
give me a little couple of these and
that
your father won a talent show and
started to take you on the road and you
said daddy i don't want to sing you
think your dad
wouldn't have worn you out with a belt
or one oh yeah no you're gonna sing
yeah you're gonna sing right now you're
gonna you're gonna put it all on the
line right if i had
i had four brothers but no i
i'd have been the best i don't care i
like the [ __ ] are you gonna that's why
you start the shows hey you're gonna
[ __ ] see him right now and then they
come out there
listen guys i love you man i love you
both thank you for coming in too
and doing oh my god hot
that's just awesome man